des gongs des harmonicas verts et des
blocs
bienvenue dans l'univers insolite et
captivant du quatuor ardeo en résidence
au théâtre de saint quentin les quatre
jeunes femmes reviennent le 14 mars
prochain pour un troisième concert quand
le théâtre nous a offert de venir
proposée
trois concerts on s'est dit qu'on allait
construire une programmation pour faire
découvrir autres autant des oeuvres
connues du répertoire classique que des
oeuvres tout à fait hors normes qui sont
pas forcément
connu du grand public ou pas encore
connus du grand public
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
trois grands compositeurs classiques
legrand beethoven plus connu pour ses
symphonies dont on découvre ici le
talent pour la musique de chambre
le romantique schumann et enfin l'oeuvre
contemporaine de l'ukrainien valentin
sylvestre of ont fait mon pas autant la
distinction entre amis classique musique
contemporaine et dont on pourrait être
surpris
on pourrait jouer huit mesures des
derniers quatuors de beethoven on
croirait que c'est de la musique
contemporaine et inversement
donc je pense qu'il faut dépasser cette
sécurité
ah ça a été écrit aujourd'hui à ça va
être ça va être bizarre et a été écrit
il ya longtemps et fait plus facilement
mais il y a quinze ans à la suite d'une
rencontre conservatoire de paris
le quatuor ardeo fait partie des
formations remarquer est récompensé de
la scène classique
carole joël yuko et mis ça ne se lasse
pas de travailler ensemble
leur ambition partagée encore de
nombreuses années leur passion commune
pour l'univers classique d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
il faut venir goûter la musique
classique en live parce que les gens
sont très surpris souvent et 10 ha mais
en fait c'est vivant oui parce que nous
on est artiste vivant